Samsung has given us Christmas early a
new flip phone a new foldable phone a
new watch
and the largest tablet they have made to
date let's talk about the Z flip 5 here
the display is almost the entire size of
the outside you got widgets here you can
type on it you can even open it up with
zero Gap look at this craftsmanship at
its finest Samsung has outdone
themselves and it is durable you can go
camcorder mode on this you can even take
photos of you on the outside cameras
it's a party on a flip phone moving to
the fold zero Gap as well beautifully
crafted the best foldable phone they
have made to date even the cameras
almost Flagship level
Snapdragon 8th Gen 2 you can zoom in and
out you can do video this is a Content
creators tool on a flip device and then
you could also pour water on these
because they're water resistant that's
right that's how good Samsung's made
these phones we poured water on them and
we took group photos because we can